first of all let me let me say that the
welcome that I've gotten here in
Hamilton has been extraordinary the
people I've met the students here the
folks and teams that I'm at in various
places during our couple of days here
have been thoughtful and open and warm
and a handful of angry people do not
Define what Hamilton is or what
democracy
[Applause]
foreign
in our democracy that people can express
their disagreement or displeasure or
even anger with various governments
that's really important uh and at the
same time our police services and
institutions will ensure that those uh
those protests remain peaceful and
law-abiding that's something that really
matters and we'll always ensure that
people are free to express the
perspective but make sure that everyone
understands that a handful of people
don't represent Hamilton